yeah what's up what do you what are you
doing here
Madden football season in America is a
competitive time an emotional time an
annual ritual that causes this man to
put hands on this pretty face man season
is the reason my hand touched your face
that time here is finally here when I
put you in your pack
Nike your car with that - fine how about
sugar and your turn did I do that I'll
get inside that coin he'll lift it all
night long I wake you up with boron
don't ask why [ __ ] up
it can break you don't go it'll break
you've got it out of this blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
it's madness season go start a Twitter
war you can smack talk trash talk al the
door I will own you with my strategy I
will write the check your face take cash
I'll beat you on your mom is it
hey Dave
day
I'm gonna pay for the car
touchdown
boy that was just bad tackling that was
awful
also we playing for real Dave a mess and
I'll be playing for real yo Dave your
house is on fire let it burn your house
is on fire that guy all right yes my boy
his house
Maggie in about 15 way to eat every
fourth was in the game
Xbox one now starting at 399